-How are you?
-Good.
-It´s always nice to see you.
Your show is very unlike --
there are a lot of travel shows.
There´s a lot of shows where
people eat food on the road.
Yours is very different,
because you are not --
You rarely talk with people
who are selling anything.
You´re not dealing
with tourist agencies.
But it must be difficult
to find your way to the places
that tour guides
don´t want to show you.
-Well, we try really hard
to get that right.
We´ve learned a lot of lessons,
some of them painfully
over the years.
You know, your local contacts
on the ground,
you know,
they have to know the area.
They have to have
a sense of humor.
They have to know
what you´re not looking for.
You know, we´re not looking
to do top-ten best lists
or a fair
and comprehensive overview.
But, you know,
some of the places that we go,
you have a bad fixer,
you´re really in trouble.
We learned --
Like, in Sicily, we had
a problematic fixer once.
And, you know, he promised,
"I´m going to take you to the
best pizzeria in all of Sicily,
which, by the way,
my brother owns."
You know? So it´s not
what we´re looking for.
-Right. Exactly.
How quickly do you know
you have a dud fixer?
-Uh...pretty quickly.
-Yeah.
-You know, I think -- I´m not
going to say which country.
We went to one country
with a New Yorker
who claimed to have
deep roots in this area.
Had spent, you know,
many years there, he said.
And we showed up with him, and
all the locals immediately --
Like, they´re talking to me
and saying --
I could hear them say,
"Who is this jerk?"
[ Laughter ]
-You have -- I don´t know
if it was the fixer´s fault,
if it was your fault,
if this was just a core fault
of the governments
that are mad at you.
You have run afoul
of some foreign governments.
-Uh, I have.
You know, those --
The worst-case scenario
is when the government
sort of tries to infiltrate
your local crew
and make things prettier
than they are, you know?
So, you know,
official bodies enter,
and we´re shooting with
a butcher in rural Romania.
You know, we like to do typical
things with typical people.
And we had a local butcher
in a rural area of Romania,
set to go with his family.
Apparently
the government found out.
They arrived the night before,
unbeknownst to us.
It´s like, "You know, your house
is not attractive enough.
We move you to nicer house.
Dress your children."
You know, an 8-year-old
and his 9-year-old sister.
"Dress them in traditional garb!
Make them dance
for the Americans!"
So it´s just this
painfully false, awkward --
These terrified children dancing
like little humble
figurines, you know?
-I remember that episode
and thinking,
"I don´t know if girls dance
at Romanian butchers, but..."
-"Do not shoot stray dogs.
Do not shoot gypsy.
Only shoot, you know, nice, new
Hilton Hotel, Cadillac."
-That´s good. When you said,
"Do not shoot stray dogs,"
I thought a different thing.
-No, that would be okay.
-I forgot you have cameras.
I forgot you have cameras.
I was like, "No, I don´t know.
That seems pretty
forward-thinking of the
Romanian government."
-A big scandal.
You know, of course, by trying
to manipulate reality,
you know, it ended up being
a very tragically funny show.
And I was all over
the newspapers in Romania
as a KGB agent, Mossad agent,
then CIA agent.
All at the same time.
-So probably not going back.
-Never say never.
-Yeah, exactly.
If you´re a Mossad agent,
you´ll find your way back in.